deliciously like potato cake the first
big thing that I remember of the kid was
taken and beans so this is like a
literal rendition except we're using the
most amazing pancetta Ernie come on
disappear go chase the mice snap a knob
to get nice and hot I'm going to turn
these beans into glamorous beans
pancetta into the pan lightly seasoned
that is cured so it doesn't need that
much seasoning now start firing off a
fan Jetta
it's amazing how individual taste of
baked beans they're somewhat bland I
always like to make them a little bit
more spicy so a nice finely chopped
chili with the seed chili in now a bit
of garlic crushed phenomenal
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fly off the chili and the garlic and
then onions my top tip for dicing finely
sliced downwards slice across then cut
down to simply dice bacon onions chili
garlic but flavor all contained in that
little pan once you sweat getting off
little bit of sugar in there the brown
sugar will start to caramelize darken
and enricher as well at the same time
well as beautiful now couple of
tablespoons spider vinegar these later
the pan got that really nice powerful
kick to it now spike that up with one of
my favorite seizing Worcester sauce
bring now the boil and add your stock of
pureed tomatoes
turn that down simmer the source of
reduce then adding the classic baked
bean haricot beans you can buy how the
beans dried or canned they're packed
with protein and have a lovely soft
texture turn down the heat and that the
beans absorb all that beautiful spicy
tomato sauce and just let that simmer
now five or six minutes now for my
potato cakes they're a fantastic way to
use leftover bored potatoes are so easy
to make I'm making a simple potato dough
by adding flour and butter to the mash
that gives it that nice sort of cakey
texture and it goes from this leftover
ball potato there's nice light flowery
potato heaven take a nice spoon of
potato lightly flour your boss we're
going to fry these crisps on the outside
and just nice and fluffy in the center
now do you kind nice and hot go start
off with olive oil into the pan so for
the butt around the outside because it
starts heating up a tire goes into the
center so once those nut brown gently
over love that nice light crisp hello
beautiful
now take them out tear the cake in the
middle and a nice beautiful spoon of
beans growing up with beans on toast as
a treat still to this day not all those
years have not changed my love or
attitude for beans especially cut my
back
[Music]
by smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and cream potato cakes comfort and
satisfaction on a plate fish fingers
with a delicious chip butty
secret of a good chip butty is in the
potato now these are Desiree potatoes
one of my first ever jobs was working at
a chip shop I used to put sacks on sacks
of potatoes into the rumble app which
was then the potato peeler all day long
today I'm gonna do something a bit
healthier for my oven chips for the
twist simply peel slice and blanch for
three to four minutes drain season and
cover well with paprika spread evenly
over an oiled baking tray and place into
a preheated oven for 20 minutes simple
as that
next up easy fish fingers this is
Pollock a really nice firm delicious
fish to the fish and finger size
patterns of fish put them onto your
plate and just lightly solve them you
can do that literally 20 minutes 30
minutes before you start cooking the
fish it firms the fish up beautifully
and it allows it to become a little more
durable especially in the pan now for
the coating start by thoroughly coating
the fish in seasoned flour and then just
rolling to get rid of those little sharp
corners because then they stop those
corners almost burning in a pan in your
egg wash and really code them wonderful
and then this is dill running the well
with a fish I'm done the deal through my
breakfast that makes it more aromatic
maven on to your breath comes nothing
wrong with the chip butty nothing wrong
with fish fingers
just give it a lovely modern twist
beautiful once the fish fingers are
thoroughly coated they're ready to pan
fry and they'll need around three
minutes on each side all the fish
fingers will be nice and crispy get a
really nice color on them first and then
we'll flip them over and finish them
with butter bring the heat up into the
pan a nice little knob of butter that
worked wonders with the breadcrumbs in
the deal I can carefully take them out
they look smell incredible so nice and
crispy now to assemble my chip butty
starting with buttered big crusty bread
[Music]
it's nice the best mop up amazing flavor
on straighten half never slice in an
angle my mouth is salivating beautiful
on weather chip butty one thing missing
and it signifies that I've never
forgotten the joy I've come from food
but my god that makes me feel like a
nine-year-old excuse me for a moment we
want to stuff my face
[Applause]
[Music]
homemade fish fingers and my ultimate
chip butty so simple to make but trust
me it tastes amazing
my ultimate Scotch eggs with a twist I
go fishing a lot and Scotch eggs are the
perfect all-in-one mini picnic papers
firstly get your eggs cooks bring water
of the ball onto the spoon and lower the
mixed in water that way they don't hit
the water and crack two and a half
minutes that will keep the center nice
slightly running now ground sausage meat
I make mine a little bit spicier on a
crumble in black pudding that helps to
season stop shades inside little touch
of salt and pepper and then just to make
it a little bit sweeter and a lot easier
for the kids to eat some grated apple
combined that blend in the apple and the
black pudding eggs once they're cooked
drain them and then run them under cold
water cracking and cooling the eggs
quickly will prevent the yolks turning
gray tap them on the side of the pan put
them back into the water and what
happens the water seeps underneath the
shell see the shell come off so much
easier it's still slightly soft and
center on that little bit of richness
for the yolk next you see yourself
organized with a mini assembly-line
siedel flour a little egg wash and bread
crumbs
take your mince golf ball-sized spread
the pate mini-state with your thumb and
then sit your egg in there spread the
sausage over the egg and you just steal
that over it's really important to keep
that nice even coating of sausage meat
around the egg you don't want it too
thick otherwise it gets too dense and it
unappetizing
give them a light dusting in the season
class you don't put the flour on the egg
wash won't stick if you don't put the
egg wash on the bread crumbs won't stick
into you roll it around shake off any
excess egg wash roll it into your
bathtub you can use this same
three-stage method to breadcrumb
anything you'd like from chicken GU
Jones and fish Phillips to FINA
schnitzel
these are panko breadcrumbs Japanese
white bread crumb
so no crust you can experiment by adding
flavors to your breadcrumbs like
Parmesan herbs or citrus zest always
like to push the actual break them into
sashimi so it gets that really nice
golden brown and stops any of the
outside burning once bread crumbs know
the eggs carefully into four centimeter
deep bath of hot vegetable oil for 10 to
12 minutes the eggs actually cook top
and running the center so the objective
logistics cook the sausage Lee and the
black pudding that's great in it Galang
grenade there's something so magical
about a scotch egg on a picnic because
it's like this little mini treacherous
useful bring them onto the paper
all them rounds just to get off any
excess oil and then to transport them
some greasing paper that for me is the
perfect start to the fishing trip
there's no wonder I never catch any fish
I'm always too busy eating my Scotch
eggs
my ultimate black pudding lace God's
eggs and irresistibly delicious picnic
breakfast mole chakra doughnuts street
food is all about satisfying your
cravings these doughnuts are sweet
sticky and absolutely delicious first
off we're going to make the dough now
this dough takes a bit of time that's
really exciting I'm heating all of the
milk with the sugar is yeast easy to get
hold off I only make fresh donuts
you need fresh year an exam of the warm
milk to the yeast will activate it which
will help the dough to rise just us give
that a quick whisk the sugar dissolves
in the milk the fresh he puts in the
grate instantly set the yeast mixture to
one side while it does its job it's not
the main dough mix and Manning half the
butter to the remaining milk that gives
the dough a nice silkiness a little
light so melt the butter into the milk
flour interest if that helps to make the
dough like a flu and you know what we
got a smooth dough it sort of Rises
evenly add a pinch of salt and two egg
yolks
pouring the warm milk and melted butter
then start over mixing it and you over
mix the dough of a doughnut but it's
really time you know my area youth in
nice and warm a little bit of smell now
I'm looking for a sort of that icky
section just dropping off the spoon nice
flower on the board take the dough out
lightly sprinkle some flour just pull it
over and push in every time and sort of
turning it almost like you're turning
the dough into itself the dough should
just sort of relaxed I should be stick
to your fingers now it's just nice and
pliable set that a nice clean Bowl or
sprinkly flour in there does it starts
to rise doesn't stick
couple that with simple
leave the dough to rise in a warm place
for 60 to 90 minutes until it's doubled
in size this stage is called proving now
I'll start proving that a panel
for the chocolate filling or ganache
pour 500 Mills of double cream into a
saucepan and add honey bring the mixture
to a gentle boil traditionally we always
put jam in there but chocolate and doner
Wow
to die for had me clean now give that
good mix the butter elevates the ganache
into a really nice shiny chocolate coat
so that will give it really nice whisky
wicked gives about aerated texture we
can actually just lightening the load a
little bit chocolate filling done put it
in the fridge to cool and it's time to
gently roll out the dough just let it
roll naturally but a centimeter half in
depth slice one two
place them on your tray and let them
rise again once the donors have had 30
to 40 minutes arrive it's time to
shallow find them in a pan filled 1/3
full with hot vegetable risen but look
this was a little pockets of air right
here we go place these in nice and
carefully or maxima but there's too many
in the pan the oil will go cold and the
donuts will come out soggy turn over
peaceful
I come out into some sugar mixed with
some malt powder 50/50 how do you tell
that actually cooked in the center tap
on top should be hollow in just sprinkle
the malt and the sugar shake off the
excess I get so excited every time I
make donuts now it was beautiful these
are delicious eating as they are the
ganache is going to be the icing on the
cake piping bag seal the bag over your
hands
don't forget pop the novel in I want the
texture almost like a little liquid
inside some a pipe then when I little
bit warm
hopefully for that burst of magic
operation donor looked up the donor
squeeze push in and fill just do start
seeing our chocolate oh yeah get that
back down
nice
get them on there I've got a little bit
heavier and we all know why no that
one's got my name on it
[Music]
that is amazing
[Music]